well it's official the movie gimmicks do
not stop at 3d all right so I've noticed
that they whoever they are trying
whatever they can to get you to the
movie theaters more often or at least
trying to get more money out of you like
3d movies in abundance and whatnot now
there's another gimmick hitting the
movie theaters and it's called D box
basically your movie theaters seat moves
with the motion on the screen like
imagine if you watched a movie and
Disneyland or something kind of would it
be like now I have seen a couple movies
indie box before what I can tell it does
enhance some of the movies to an extent
some like I thought Nightmare on Elm
Street was enhanced cuz you can feel
like the heartbeats in the chair when
people were freaking out and I'm not one
for those jump scares so whatever Freddy
would jump out and claw someone like the
chair would jump like that like imagine
someone behind your seat going boom like
every time something jumped out at you
with like frame perfect accuracy I
thought that was kind of cool it helped
the experience the Tron Legacy trailer
and D box looks really cool like your
seats moving with the bike chase scene
it was cool but the second time I saw
inception I saw it in D box and movies
still amazing but the D box it's more
like shitbox inception is really more
about dialogue and concept more than
action you see this when you're in the D
box seat because there were scenes when
my D box he didn't move for like 30
minutes just sat there turned like the
seat I'm sitting in now and at 8 bucks
more a ticket for D box yeah that's like
$8 on top of the $10 you already pay for
a ticket I felt ripped off and all the
movie theater prices for everything do
stack so if you go and see if 3d movie
in D box has $10 for the movie ticket
three more dollars for the 3d and eight
more dollars for the D box which comes
out to over twice as much as a normal
movie theater ticket that [ __ ] had
better be like the holodeck in next
generation if I'm shelling out that much
cabbage it's just not I mean like I say
if you have a solid movie you won't need
to rely on the 3d conversion in the D
box gimmicks if the movie is really
solid then you might feel like the D box
is worth it if not you might not and
again inception to solid and I didn't
feel the D box was worth it so there
that is think of it this way when they
have it in their heads that taking and
slathering movies with fake [ __ ] and
overpriced gimmicks make for a better
movie they have taken their movie from
being like Natalie Portman you know good
natural my wife to being like Joan
Rivers fake loud violating to about
three of your senses and your wallet
and yeah I'm loved but this [ __ ] yeah
it's all real so have you guys tried out
this whole D box gimmick and if you have
what did you think of it comment below
let me know and if you like or agree
with this video then you might want to
check out an article I wrote on schmoes
no comm titled bigger versus better and
yeah it's about movies
put the link in the box below go check
it out I think you'll like it and of
course if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more
[Music]